- So what should we do, GaryVee?
Let's wrap this up.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- What should we do?
What should people do?
- People should
fuckin' stop complaining.
- [Joe] Right. Good call.
- People should figure
out who the fuck they are.
- [Joe] Good call.
- People should not
listen to America propaganda of
fixing the shit they suck at.
They should be tripling
down at what they're good at.
They should be
competent in certain areas,
but you're not
gonna become Beyoncé
or your bone
structure is a certain way.
You're not gonna
solve everything.
Your IQ can get a little bit
better but don't worry about
the incremental, figure out
what fuckin' puts you on fire
and you're halfway decent at.
If you're lucky enough
right now to be listening
and you're good
at what you like,
become tunnel fucking vision.
Because there's way
too many voices telling you
what and how and
here's the other thing
and this is the big one, Joe,
because you have a
humongous audience,
the biggest thing that
I've seen dividends from
have the conversation with the
person that's holding you back.
The reason most people
who are listening right now
are not doing that thing,
is they're worried
about the opinion of somebody.
Usually, their mother.
Usually, their father
and the reality is is that your
spouse may be the person
holding you back and you have to
have that conversation.
- [Joe] Cut 'em off.
- [Gary] We have to get to a
place where you're doing you
because the number one thing
that scares the fuck out of me
is regret and you're
gonna sit there at 72
and you're gonna say
I wish, I wish, I wish
and whether that's money or
spend more time
with your family.
There's a
million ways to do this.
Not everybody
wants to buy the Jets,
not everybody
wants to smoke weed
on the beach
in The Bahamas.
Everybody's got a
different fucking thing,
figure out what
you're fucking thing is
and stop making
fucking bullshit excuses.
Who the President is,
your mom did this.
I missed it. I had
that idea for Uber.
Then why didn't you
fuckin' do it, dick?